all right I think we've waited long
enough and the winner of game spots game
of the year for 2014 is
Middle Earth shadow of Mordor is
GameSpot's game of the year for 2014 and
we're doing something for the very first
time here at GameSpot we actually have
game director Michael the platter from
monolith right here congratulations
thank you so much to you and the team
the team don't know that you guys have
won at all I think they're probably
learning about it right now I'm going to
mention there's a few glasses being
raised at monolith as we speak so
congratulations it's obviously a new IP
you guys aren't the biggest team in the
world in terms of game development
especially for a game of this type what
does it feel like winning a game of the
Year award kind of what does it mean to
like the longevity of a franchise like
this kind of a little bit lost for words
because you know all of those things you
said we're really true it's our first
open-world game it's a first
third-person action game it's the first
game in what hopefully gets to become a
new and new franchise so sort of a bit
overwhelming let's talk a little bit
about the sort of in section of what
this game was because obviously a lot of
stories out there about you know your
guys association with Warner Brothers
and whatnot about this originally not
being a middle-earth game at all we
certainly you know we took a lot of our
inspiration from Arkham in the sense of
that's how we wanted to approach the
license in the same way that you know
the Arkham games were coming out in
parallel with Chris Nolan's Batman movie
right but they absolutely weren't the
game of the movie it was you know Chris
Nolan's trying to make the best possible
Batman movie he can and roxtor he's
trying to make you know the most amazing
Batman game that they can and we really
took that as well and and everyone from
Peter Jackson to Warner Brothers to the
licensed ORS was so supportive in that
don't do a movie game do the you know do
the best game that you can so that was
it was great to have that sort of
support and that they were really the
only two things we ever got pressure on
was was quality and innovation you know
really push to try and do something
different and bring something new to it
so what was that innovation as far as
you were concerned because obviously you
know you
go in so many directions with this
franchise but also with the genre and
it's a genre that we've kind of gotten
used to over the past you know five six
seven years on consoles yeah I mean you
touched on it a little bit before we've
saying you know it was our first go and
being a smaller team and wanting to do
something new and wanting to use the
power of the next generation of consoles
that we really wanted to enable players
to go into middle-earth and create their
own stories like obviously we put a lot
of effort into the story because you
have to be very very respectful of that
we're huge fans of middle-earth but
really you know the biggest stories that
are told in that universe are going to
be told in the films and the books but
what we can do as a game that no other
medium can do is let people make their
own stories so that was really a sort of
central goal right from the start and
then once we thought sort of that was
like we started thinking one of the most
important relationships players actually
have in action games and it's really
with your enemies and with your with the
villains but of course historically
people put a lot of effort into NPCs and
friends and allies and like okay what if
we what if we take all that effort and
all of those relationship and put it on
to the bad guys and let you build these
really meaningful personal relationships
and create your own villains in the game
as well so that was sort of the
inception of that idea that became the
Nemesis system and the discussions for
this year's game adir as with every year
that I've been involved here GameSpot
went on for hours and hours and I feel
like we sort of tear apart every game
mechanically in as many ways as we can
to try and come up with and what was the
best game of the year not just
mechanical actually in terms of every
aspect of it but one thing that kept
coming up at Kevin in our discussions
was and had the Nemesis system sort of
changed the way you approach and almost
everything in in terms of the
third-person open-world adventure game
instead of you you know basically having
the breadcrumb trail and picking and
choosing what you wanted to do
sometimes just instances happened like
over merchants and gameplay out of
nowhere with you know when you hadn't
anticipated it almost like you were
playing the game too
the games rules rather than to the beat
you wanted to do yeah it was interesting
too because I mean ever every year it's
a little bit different in terms of okay
does it go to the game it was just the
most well executed game of its type does
it go to the game that's going to mean
the most in 10 years in terms of what it
introduced or there are so many
different ways to go but this was an
interesting one because you could you
could say both about it
you know on one hand it you know it was
it was the best game of its type really
that came along this year and in it you
know when when I would say that
Assassin's Creed is the closest analog
it was certainly the best Assassin's
Creed game that yes they came out this
year and there were a couple of yes
there were but but beyond that it also
came down to what what thing did we see
in games that we can see other
developers learning from and being
inspired by in the years to come and the
Nemesis system was the thing that
clearly came up more often than any
other individual game mechanic that we
actually discussed this year in fact I
would say in terms of individual game
changing mechanics we didn't actually at
least not in that you know supposed to
triple a space we didn't really see a
whole lot of that yeah this year and so
this was kind of an easy choice in terms
of the mechanic we thought was worth you
know most worth being ripped off yeah I
mean I would tell you that during our
discussion of like games not winners
past I mean with Gears okay we're on the
active reload in the cover with Demon
Souls and that kind of multiplayer
overlap you know those are all things
that we have since seen propagate
throughout the game industry like
wildfire and I think if stuff like the
Nemesis system does that we'll all be
the better for it
but there was also another part of it
and I we I feel like we often get really
stuck on the Nemesis system guys talk
about the game and I covering up this
this many times which is okay so we've
seen similar mechanics before but we've
never seen some of these little touches
that can make the difference between a
game that just has a lot of stuff and a
game that has a lot of stuff most of
which is actually meaningful yeah and
that was a big part of the discussion as
well so for example you know you you
can't just go in there and know that you
know hey I've played I played Arkham
before I've played Assassin's Creed
before I know how to respond all of
these attacks and just do the thing
until everybody's dead oh no you're not
pull off that [ __ ] in shadow immortal
yeah you have mechanics that instead of
being like and I hate to I hate to do
the little Assassin's Creed comparison
so forgive me an advance but it's
sometimes it's easy to draw a comparison
between a game it does this thing but
doesn't do it as well as the thing this
game does and so you have like here's
the collection of mechanics you could
use your smoke bombs if you want but who
cares you never need to do that please
play the damn thing without it here's
suddenly a case where it's like what are
all of the things I can do and how do I
need to use them to actually conquer the
challenge in front of me to not keep
getting killed by all these freezes yes
and certainly you have suddenly the
addition of challenge means that you
also have the addition of meaning to
mechanics that in other games are just
there to be there now you have mechanics
that are there because there's actually
worth in testing them in exploring them
and actually sometimes using them when
you might not have if the game didn't
prompt you and didn't really necessitate
that kind of approach you know you've
got the enemies with the you know the
different weaknesses and strengths and
when I first heard about that I was like
oh well it's just a thing developers say
no this wasn't just a thing developers
say in this case this was a real
meaningful thing and you know that's
that's one of the great things too we're
so used to just hearing the you know the
you know they're just words anybody can
say these or line items on okanagan on a
P or list yeah one of the things that
sort of stands out to me about this
maybe you can speak to how you guys felt
on on the development side is there's a
lot of rules that we sort of come to
understand in in this genre that you
guys either ignore or actively go
against for instance the idea that if
you lose a fight you don't just hit
reload and you try and fight them again
it's actually not just going to be as
hard it's going to be harder than the
last time and were you guys ever worried
that you were going to step into ground
that we're going to make gamers feel
uncomfortable because so much of what we
see with big triple-a games is like
hazing players and trying to make them
not feel like it's too difficult uh yeah
very much because the it was really
scary at a lot of points to do that
because we had a mechanic
that was built on you having more of an
emotional connection to your enemy so
you have to love to heat them okay and
the only way to develop that true hatred
is to have them take things from you or
beat you or frustrate you so you know
even things of discussions like we could
have had an easy mode and if we did the
game would have fundamentally been
broken because if you could just hack
and slash your way through the game
without having to stop and think without
getting killed without seeing these guys
level up without the world evolving
people wouldn't have got to you know
experience the Nemesis system and I mean
to be to be brutally honest we saw that
the people who were the most the people
who are the very sort of end of the bell
curve in terms of their coordination and
skill and their ability the people who
found the game most easy were also the
ones who found the Nemesis system least
engaging oh well there may be much more
the cases you know and we're looking at
this with DLC too as well I think
actually a hard mode is probably what we
needed even more in some ways than it
than an easy mode but what we did was we
made sure that you had to stop and think
that your enemies were going to annoy
you frustrate you attack you you know
piss you off
but that you had the tools that if you
stopped plan studied their weaknesses
you could also take them apart really
easily so you could for example have
someone who was impossibly hard unless
you studied his weakness and used his
sphere and then he'd run screaming like
a baby and you could just just take him
down so we wanted to sort of maximize
the I guess the tangent between okay
it's gone from being credibly hard to
incredibly easy because you've
manipulated the system in the right way
and you really get to own these guys and
take them down except of course that
sometimes they then come back to sort of
yeah have another go at you again and
one of the things that keeps coming off
on Twitter and the comments on GameSpot
is 23 sorry 2014 was one of those years
where we saw a lot of games either
established franchises or new ones just
technically have a lot of issues with
them one of the things that came up in
our discussion I guess is we kept
mentioning things like the Nemesis
system because stuff like the combat the
world exploration and then also
technically
there was nothing there that stood out
as like it was all kind of smooth it was
not flawless I wouldn't say but there
was nothing we need to take issue with
it all technically you guys made a game
just you know I've never had any
problems with it doesn't come up in
discussions and the internet seems so
sensitive to it now
how did you guys as a relatively you
know not a massive like Ubisoft outfit
who's got seemingly millions of people
working on a game a created game the Kay
marriage in a timely fashion but also
didn't have any like major technical
hiccups I think I mean you know it's
sort of a cliche but making games is
hard obviously and I think partly it was
the factor that it was our first go at
this type of game so we were so
incredibly paranoid and so very full
that we did close things down early
production was really diligent about
closing things down at QA did just a
phenomenal job
having our own engine you know in our
own tech team and having those guys on
site was hugely integral to it so it
just really was you know which big goal
of ours it was a priority to do that
because you don't get two chances like
yeah if we had have come out and
stumbled on our first go we'd never be
getting a second one basically when did
when did the point come were you you
felt confident about this game was it
you know when you went gold or was it
like a week after launch sure probably I
guess Thanksgiving okay
you are giving thanks oh yeah exactly I
was like you know like a month after
launch where you've seen the reviews and
you've seen things settle in and you can
see the user reviews and you can see
people playing it and you can see people
streams so yes a month or so after after
we came out I guess so you guys ready
and willing to take another bite at us
jump back into the maelstrom of game
development again well that's I mean and
that's why it's it's so incredibly
exciting and meaningful to get an award
like this as well because it really does
help us have that chance there was
actually the other day Ken Levine
from Bioshock he wrote a pretty cool
blog post and he was talking about
bananas's system and talking about
procedural storytelling and so on and
was really complimentary and it was
great in it but he described the Nemesis
system in shadow of Mordor
much the sort of baby steps towards a
new type of storytelling and dynamic
storytelling and that's that's really
true you know we've learned so much in
the course of doing this game and are so
excited to get to apply that knowledge
and kind of move forward excellence
Michael the platter congratulations once
again from Middle Earth shadow of Mordor
and wedding sports game of the year at
2014 thank you Ray
hooray